oh wait let me fix the chat i did not warm up i did not warm
up oh wow well we'll talk of it we'll talk a bit before i
start singing uh hold on actually since i will be talking um
Let me put out some music, some...
We tree...
Ah, ghost!
Boo!
Yeah.
Yeah, be frightened, be frightened, be frightened.
Welcome to karaoke!
Hey, who just unsubscribed?
It's not like we get to 4-4-4-4-4-4-4-4-4-4.
and I stopped singing.
I just wanted it up because I was like, oh, we might make it
today.
And that would be cool if we could do it on stream.
The spookiest of spooky numbers.
You just subscribe.
We're 44 away, 43 away, 42 away.
Let's see.
Hey, how have you guys been?
How are you guys doing today?
Happy Thursday.
Yeah.
My brain is so scrambled on times and days.
Everything is...
Am I moving today yet?
Am I packing today?
Well, packing always.
Am I moving?
Minto can bring it up more and more.
Choo!
Moi, moi.
Choo.
Tachi, thank you so much for the five gift.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello, me, Tom, and I was like, you're nice to have some
Minky singing this fine evening after a long day of bad
paint and work.
No, God, no!
That's okay, Minky's here.
Okay, well, I'll serenade you, hopefully, then.
Forget your worries.
I chose a lot of...
I wanted to listen to a lot of Dad Rock today.
Or rather sing, I guess.
I don't know.
I have a list of songs.
4-4-4-4.
Thank you.
Kyrgyz, thank you so much for your 25 months.
Holy cow.
Thank you.
Rush, thank you for the five gifted.
Zen, thank you for the five gifted.
56k subs left?
No?
Wait.
Is it that many?
Am I wrong?
I mean, have you ever heard of this awesome group, idol
group called Den Setu.exe?
They recently released a song called Burn On, which has over
76k views on it.
I think everyone needs to listen to it.
Oh my gosh, Virulent, that's so crazy.
You would mention that because I was like, oh, what if I
sung a cover of that song today?
Because it's so cool, right?
Oh, for 500k.
Oh, no, I don't care about that.
I care about 4444.
4, 4, 4 4 Pao, Boo Panda, thank you so much for the 50
gifted!
Did you guys see my Twitter this morning?
Did you see?
That I I got invited.
I'm sorry, I could not say anything.
They were like you are not allowed to speak about it until
June 4th This time, I literally scheduled the tweet at the
exact time that we were allowed to talk about it.
Because I was so excited!
Was that your little secret trip?
It was.
Oh, blue eyes, thank you so much for the fun, good turn.
500k is tomorrow's goal.
Sure, sure, sure.
We might be a little jelly Colonel Minky.
I got invited by Bandai Namco To the Ace Combat 8 Wings of
Thieves What do you call it?
A...
Event...
The Event TM I...
Got invited They flew me out They flew me out They put me in
a super fancy hotel And I got to go They drove us to this
studio and look at this look at this this is the first room
we walked into hold on whoa I will I my eyes were probably
like oh peeka peeka whoa so cool the screen on the ceiling
the screens everywhere like that big big long screen it was
so cool It was so, so cool.
And they gave us a little presentation here.
And this is, they showed us like the trailer.
They showed us kind of about like Ace Combat series.
They're like, you are in Strange Real.
And then they showed the release date.
And they showed Ace Combat Zero.
And I was like, and are you now the ghost of Thief?
No, there's an actual ghost in the game.
But, and then the brand director came out and he gave a
little speech and they were like, they were like, your
schedule for today is you, you get to play the game for
three hours and then take a small break.
to play more of the game and i was like whoa so um yeah i
got to play up to mission five um that was as much as that
they would let us play it was kind of like a demo version um
but i got to play up to mission five and then afterwards
they let us record us playing mission four nine and And so I
have footage of me playing.
Hold on, let me show you.
This is me beating Mission 4 of 97% damage.
Yeah, baby.
We did that.
What a gamer.
Absolutely.
No flares left either.
Okay, to be fair, you have like, you have like five flares.
To be fair, you have like five flares.
I will tell you guys, oh my goodness.
First of all, the game is like cutscene city.
I think probably the first 20 minutes of the game at least
are like all cutscene.
It's a really long opening cutscene.
Very, very long.
You start, you get rescued, and then they're like, hey, you
can fly.
Okay, you're now with this guy.
You're now with this guy.
His name is Cope.
And you're with Cope, and you start.
So it's kind of cool.
You have the Joker squad, and you're part of the Joker
squad, and then there is the Shadow squad.
And Shadow 22 is who you're kind of...
You're beefing with...
But...
You're with Cope, and Cope dies!
Oh my gosh, bam bam!
And then, he's like, in your head.
Like, talking to you.
And he's just like, I guess...
I guess I'm not done with this life yet.
So he's kind of, like, coaching you.
It's kind of fun.
It's not spoilers.
Actually, because people already found this out.
people were so observant I think Ace Combat fans were like
so hungry frothing at the mouth that they were like oh so
this guy is like I already saw tweets about it but it also
happens in the opening cutscene quite literally but yeah so
it's really interesting concept I think it's fun but that's
all I'll say I say the characters are really, really fine.
You have...
Everybody knows Trish.
Because everybody is simping over Trish.
She's very cute.
At the beginning of the game, she's very like...
She's like a circus pilot.
She's like, I'm going to do tricks in the air.
And then...
I don't know what happened because obviously I skipped
missions.
They only let us play...
So when I played Mission 11...
They were like, she was like, is this really what I have to
do?
You know, like her character development was like, oh, we
love a circus girl.
Yeah, she's very cute.
She's very cute.
But basically, you have to, the wings of Thieve is like a
concept.
They're like, after Cope is gone, you become the wings of
Thieve.
Oh, Cope was killed in action.
Like, you are now the wings of Thieve.
And so that's how you kind of adopt the title.
So it's your true journey to becoming an Ace.
It's pretty cool.
I just realized I've been a member for 10 months now.
So here's 10 bucks.
Thank you, Maddie.
So glad you got to play Ace Combat early.
It must have been exciting.
It was very exciting.
if you guys watch okay so i think i could probably do
mission 9 now holy matara was sitting next to me right she
was also at the event and she literally hands head in her
hands like she was like she was like girl this game is hard
Mission 9 is, oh, and then it starts with this, like, the
OST is phenomenal.
Chef's Kiss.
I've already pre-ordered the vinyl, but it's, the Mission 9
starts with this sound, like the song that goes, and if you
re-watch the trailer from State of Play, from my watch that
song or like that that sound play and just i my trauma
reflex was just like i was like oh not not again to be fair
to matto this isn't her this is her first rodeo yeah yeah
yeah she's never played before so actually one of the bandai
people came up to me i was playing the game and he came up
to me and he was like mint um did you Did you switch to
expert controls yet?
And I was like, you can switch to expert controls?
I was like, oh, thank you.
I didn't, I did it.
Because there were like some things that, you know,
there was some things that were like, not that they were
allowed and not allowed, but like, like, like it was still a
demo, right?
So, They did give us like this, really, really...
What was it called?
Hold on, I have...
I don't want to post it because I don't know if it's not
allowed or something.
It was a gameplay guide, and it had like...
I kind of wish I was able to keep it.
It had like game overview, the story, campaign mode, quick
start guide, user interface, like terminology.
Like, they really, I feel like, put in the effort for people
that were unaware of, you know, as if it's their first time
playing or aren't super, you know, aware of, like, stuff in
Ace Combat.
So excited for Ace Combat 8, bought the Collector Edition.
Yeah!
So...
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, look at...
So this...
Wait.
And then ask Matara if I could pose it.
Where's the back of her head?
It's probably fine.
Look at her.
She's a pilot.
That's Matara clone.
There she is.
Actually, we didn't play on these, though.
We played in like a...
In a...
In the...
The thing is...
is ace combat is a very overstimulating game and i don't
play in the dark i've never played video games in the dark
and it was a very dark room and so by the end of the day i
actually had like a migraine i was like but yeah it's bad
for your eyes right um it was It was just a lot of like
everything for so long.
I feel weird gaming in the dark.
Me too, me too.
But also look at these, oh my gosh.
They did serve us food as well.
We were there for a really long time.
Like seven hours ish or something?
It was a really long time.
But they, so they fed us too.
Oh, that's me.
And that's my cranberry juice.
And then look.
Look at the cakes.
Look at the cake.
And look at the cookie.
Oh, I took notes.
Hold on.
I took notes while I was playing.
So I wouldn't forget anything.
I wrote, it's very cinematic.
Extremely cinematic.
Um...
Like, you don't even reach the sortie until Mission 3.
And then, your name is Rex.
But the girl on- I wrote the girl.
But Trisha calls you Ray.
And I'm like, why do you do that?
I was going insane.
I was like, you can't be Rex and Ray at the same time.
You can't- That's not allowed.
That's not allowed.
Hmm.
Shadow 22.
I just wrote Shadow 22 exclamation point exclamation point
exclamation point And then I wrote Mission 5.
Oh god.
My notes are quite detailed.
I could be a gaming journalist.
I hate IGN if you need a real reporter.
Mayors, welcome to my pushups.
Thank you.
Ray Ray also means king like Rex.
But why does she call you Ray?
Would you please?
Or would I kindly?
But I do have some of my footage.
I'm scared.
Hold on.
Wait, that's the wrong footage.
Ace Combat.
Let me see.
Hmm.
Hold on.
I gotta open these first.
No, no.
Open.
Oh.
Let's see.
Thank you so much, Minto, for the karaoke.
It was my birthday yesterday.
Forever mortal.
Happy birthday.
I always love to make Minto fan art.
I listen to your singing all day.
I'll be in Aibu forever.
Thank you.
Happy birthday.
Let's see what we have here.
Oh, it's so exciting.
Oh my gosh.
When the, I think she's the commander, when she started
talking in state of play, I was like, where have I heard
this voice before?
And I go like, and then I was like, oh wait, I see.
I was like, I recognize this voice.
Why?
Oopsie.
um yeah you have trish oh i can't you have costor and i
cannot remember the other guy um oh professor professor um
and they all protect you costor is so funny because he like
is really into rock music and like some other uh i think
they were part of the queen unit you have the joker unit
which you're part of and then the queen unit and i think he
was and uh Koster was like, oh my gosh, you are like, you
are the, you are the, you are the singer of my favorite
band.
Freddie Mercury.
He really does kind of look like Freddie Mercury.
You don't count as a gaming journalist?
Don't insult yourself so harshly.
Let's see.
This is my footage, right?
I'm so bad.
Oh, wait.
What mission is this?
I don't know.
Hold on.
I'm trying to look at these before I show you them.
Because I'm like...
Oh, yeah, and you also get to, like, custom...
Oh.
Oh, it's Mission 9.
I think I could do it now.
But I was struggling.
I was...
Oh, geez.
Okay, hold on.
I'll show you guys the song even.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
I can't hear it, I can't hear it.
Poor eyes.
That's a professor.
Wait.
Fit to screen.
There we go.
Okay, hold on.
Uh, okay, sorry.
Let's just be...
Let's just be you guys.
Just pretend I'm here, okay?
Okay, hold on.
That was weird.
Ah!
Okay.
Uh, now?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, hold on.
The Lamb Battleship!
problem
oh my oh the land battleship
and then they're just like okay canons firing and i'm like
this is my first time playing this mission i'm pretty sure
so i'm like oh no
we will be in visual range in the land battleship soon And
then everything is happening.
It's, it's, you have missiles and you have, uh, they're
railgun warning!
Oh my god, I was like, ah!
I'm like, get me out of here.
Oh, it looks amazing.
The game, hold on.
Oh my gosh, if you...
It's just me crashing and burning up.
And then also me running out of time.
because you have to like shoot the treads but oh
what happened to karaoke I was um actually uh I'm not
stalling but I do um have to wait for my water to heat up so
uh I just thought I'd share this for now oh that is that's
more of the hold on wait was that the mission hold on sorry
I'm opening up to the game is so pretty and then yes yes
okay hold on The game is so cool.
And...
Uh...
The game is so pretty.
And... It's so cool.
Look at this.
Okay, this was like...
Such a neat part of the game.
Because...
Oh my god, look at it!
It's gorgeous!
It's just beautiful!
It's the status on the Queens.
Queen Flight is fending off some hostiles.
So you have to...
You're searching for these transport ships.
and you have to you're stuck you see on the radar you're
stuck in like a no like a no radar zone I know the clouds
look amazing right and so you have to find them by following
their trails don't worry about us shouldn't we go help them
see that's how I found them because I can see like isn't
that oh it's so cool visual search only yeah yeah that'll
see the feathered one It's so awesome.
Yeah, the Contrails.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then you're... But it's kind of terrible because...
They're like... They're like three groups of three, but I
didn't hear the third one, so I shot down finally the second
group, and they were like, all right, one more group to go,
and I'm fighting the shadow unit at the same time, and I'm
like...
What do you mean?
And it's one of those, like, you have to get super close to,
like, launch a missile and everything.
I was like, oh, my God.
I was like, can't be out of here!
Oh, it's so beautiful, though.
Holy cow.
I was, like, so impressed with the visuals.
I was like, this is...
Missile incoming.
I was like, please.
No, my special ammo.
Transport is no more.
I don't even know where they are.
Yeah, look at him!
I caught that guy!
He's going down!
Oh, I think I accidentally lost.
Meow.
So many missiles, so many... hold on, I'm trying to find
where the...
Wait, hold on, I want to show when they come in.
Oh yeah!
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
It's so cool.
I feel like I don't want to show so much of my gameplay
because it's nonsensical.
Plus you'll see when I play it in October.
But yeah, so we got to leave with a little bit of a swag bag
too.
the gameplay is incredibly it looks so fine I mean it looks
so fine because it is so fine so um yeah I'm excited I'm so
excited yippee I'm gonna go grab some water and then we can
sing baby we'll sing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what's in the
swag bag they give us it's like a bag like an actual bag and
then it has some patches you can put on it and then there
was a glasses case no glasses though glasses case and um
there was like a little flight tag and uh oh some some
microfiber cloths for the glasses they did not include
wait sorry i know i missed some i was so happy you got to go
to this meeting though i can't wait to play it for myself
almost everything i've seen of ace Combat 8 has me excited.
Yeah, thank you.
I almost didn't go because it was like so...
I survived Mission 9 and all I got was this t-shirt.
I wish!
Um, but, uh, I almost didn't go because of like the timing
of my move and everything.
Um, but I had never gone to this type of event before.
I've never been flown out by a company before.
um so you know i was really honored that they would even
offer the opportunity to me and so i was like well it is
only like three days i i went i flew i went to the event the
next day and i flew home the next day like kind of boom boom
boom and uh they it was like i felt like truly like it was a
red carpet event like they treated us so well they were so
nice Like overall it was I'm really glad I went for the
experience So let me go grab some water and then we sing
Yeah Sing let's sing I do have not quite a set list a
Suggested song that I wrote for my brain so that I don't
forget stuff, but I would like to sing
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
I spelled that wrong.
I was like, why does that look weird?
Lucky.
Oh.
Hold on.
I mean.
There we go.
Let's sing.
I can't stop the loneliness I can't stop the loneliness Why
is that?
I can't stop I can't stop A lot, lot, lot,
lot.
A lot, lot, lot...
...A lot, I'm...
...I'm still with you.
I
can't stop
Oh, I missed it.
I missed it.
I can't stop the loneliness Yes, yes, yes, yes, can I ask
for help me?
Yeah, yes,
can I ask for help me?
Can anyone help me?
Don't
worry about me, can I stop?
Can I ask for help me?
I can't stop the loneliness Why do you say that?
I know, it's like.
It's like I can't stop the loneliness.
It's like a coal station.
It's like it's like it's like I can't stop.
It's like stuck in that four.
It's like stuck there.
Yippee!
Thank you.
Yeah, the people unsubbing.
Keep it at the number.
Keep it at four, four, four, four, four.
Four!
Thank you!
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you so much.
to get even more.
But this is the number I really, really wanted.
This is the number I wanted so much.
Because it's so spooky.
Four million bone necks.
Yeah.
What about 6666666 That could be a good one to work towards
Hmm It's pretty spooky too 444 death death death Death death
death Yeah exactly just like the cover Speaking of do you
guys want me to cover bird solo person Burn on Hot blooded
heroine Minto Phantom version Solo?
Should I try?
Wait, one second.
There we go.
Give it a shot.
If you guys don't know, Dentsu 2, idol group that I'm a part
of.
444, 444 on June 444 at 444.
PST!
Whoa.
Whoa!
Wait, you're right!
That's crazy!
It only would have been better if it was April 4th!
Oh my god.
Whoa.
Wait, that's freaky.
That's freaky!
Whoa, so many fours!
It's a death party!
What was I gonna say?
I don't remember.
Oh, oh, Den said that!
exe we released a new song burn on hot blooded heroine it's
very hot blooded and the music video is a lot of fun and we
put a lot of effort into it it's our little brain baby so
please go watch it we try to get it to 100k streams on the
den sets a channel so let's sing it let's sing it let's sing
it baby oh burn on hot wait hot Blooded Heroin Binto Solo.
Oh, wait, let me...
There!
Okay.
Let me try.
Oh, gosh.
I don't think I've ever sung it solo before.
This is going to be an interesting experience.
Let me get the...
Wait.
Let me test the audio.
I don't know how it sounds, actually.
Should be okay, maybe.
Yuletay!
Yosei!
Yokai!
We are...
Dance up to a EXO!
Show the world that we wanted!
Show them nothing can stop it!
Break up!
Break the cycle of fate we're pushing through.
Turn our eyes to the future!
Cause we're stronger than ever!
Break up!
And life's mightier than the sword.
Fighting on, burning like the sun as it sets upon the down I
love.
My heart is set aflame by a call from up above.
Protecting what is sacred requires sacrifice.
Summer sign until the ends of the earth, take up the fire.
Though the night may fall as misty sadness blooms from our
eyes, hand in hand we'll stand together with you by our
side, tall as three with the strength from inside the spirit
of the misfit in me serves for our electric town we'll pave
the way through all the hay light up from dajikon the manga
our passion heard in every word with voices ringing out all
over the world let's look ahead past all the dread and see a
brighter world unfolding instead you'll see that one day the
NPC will become Our new heroine, Akiba, I'll fight for you
For all Otaku Still one of you Burning on Show out!
Show the world that we want it Show up, nothing can stop it
Break it up Break the cycle of fate we're pushing through
Break up Turn our eyes to the future Comes with stronger
than ever than the sword fighting on a battle's never lost
if there's still a fire in my soul kindle it with hope let
it rise pierce the call what's another round for an undying
flame never fading out in front of the crowd lighting the
way
oh i can't do this next part oh no i need It's me, Miki!
Blooming again, a rose that's stronger than it seems And
though the wind will try to shake her Break her, her petals
burst through the wind chill And though the heat and rain
are relentless And though the seasons change, we're rooted
to our dreams We're letting the storm once more!
Like a dragon rising, the town's gonna be reviving Akiba
from Kureta, this wave I'm riding, turning pain to power
Tengoku, Amamoro, Kaizhou, that's the goal All these
monsters laughing, they don't know That they're messing with
the MVP Maho, Ninoin, Meido Cafe, Gei Senta, Mukaneja We
will save our Akiba I've always known I'm not alone But now
I truly do believe in my soul This time I swore I'll stand
once more What once was broken has now become whole Our
voice is loud, one with the crowd They shake us up, but
we'll never go down So stand your ground and sing it proud
Our battle cry is ringing out through the town
We'll pave the way through all the hate Line up from Na
'rikan to Mandirake Our passion heard in every word With
voices ringing out all over the world Let's look ahead, pass
all the dread And see a brighter world that's holding us in
You'll see that one day the FBC With Akiba, I'll fight for
you For all Otaku Still one of you Burning on Shout out!
Show the world that we want it Sing out!
Show them nothing can stop it Break out!
Break the cycle of fate we're pushing through Wake up!
Turn our eyes to the future Rise up!
Cause we're stronger than ever!
Raise up!
Van light's mightier than the sword
I love that song please stream a lot and lots and lots and
lots Thank you, thank you, thank you
Lotsa, lotsa, lotsa, lotsa.
Yay!
Thank you, guys.
Thank you!
I just subscribed.
Welcome!
I haven't, like, warmed up.
That's okay.
It's fine.
Let's...
Let's do this one.
I have a whole list.
I will do this one before I do this one.
I kind of just have a lot of dad music.
This one is not so dad music.
But I don't know.
I was just super into dad music today.
Have you guys ever get in that mood where you're just like,
yeah, I want to listen to some dad rock.
So I was going to sing a song, but I think it's tough for
right now.
I'll sing it later.
I'm always in that mood.
So true.
I don't know.
Like recently, I've just been really into listening to like
70s and 80s music.
I'm like, yeah.
Let's see.
Okay.
I'm just going to sing this one for fun, though.
Everything is for fun.
I like just singing for fun.
Actually, I watched on the way back from the trip.
the ace combat trip i uh wait there was a there's a movie
with hugh jackman where he it plays or he plays a guy who
was impersonating not impersonating like uh imposter no um
what's the word when you dress up but it's not the person
what's hugh jackman yeah cosplay well it know like uh
there's like elvis elvis is famously impersonator wait did i
say that that sounds so negative it sounds negative you're
impersonating me it is an impersonator oh well yeah like an
elvis oh okay um so hugh jackman is playing a guy who is
impersonating neil diamond but there's this guy on tick tock
that like sings hugh jackman songs but he sings them really
funny because he goes like because the way hugh jackman
sings is like especially in i always say sometimes when i'm
hungry and i wish someone would offer me a sacrifice i just
kind of stand in the middle of my maid cafe and i like kind
of will it into the universe and i go like why won't someone
offer me a loaf of bread because that's how Hugh Jackman
sings in Le Messe and so the guy on TikTok kind of like
sings all of these songs similarly to how Hugh Jackman sings
and then once it came out that Hugh Jackman was going to be
singing as this guy trying to be Neil Diamond it was like
sweet Caroline bread bread bread and so i watched this movie
and i couldn't stop i had to i had to i had to stop myself
it's so it's so goofy to me so anyway that's my story anyway
let's sing sweet caroline because i've been thinking about
this song and brad brad brad sorry i went on a bit of a
tangent to explain Okay, okay.
Where
it began I can't begin to know when But then I know it's
growing strong Was in the spring And spring became the
summer Would I believe you'd meow along?
Meow's Meow and Meow's We're reaching out Meow and me
Sweet meow, meow, meow Meow, meow, meow Good times never see
you So good!
So meow!
I've been inclined, meow, meow, to believe I never would,
but now I, meow, I look at the night, and it don't seem so
lonely, we fill it up with only meow.
Meow and runs off my shoulders How could I meow when holding
you?
Meow
Meow and meow Meow and now Meow and me Meow and you
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow Good dance never seems so meow,
so meow, so meow, so meow, so meow, so meow, so meow, so
meow, so meow,
so meow,
meow, so meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow,
meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow,
meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, And I went to
meow!
You never saw it coming!
Sleep, meow, meow, meow, meow The dogs never seem so meow,
so meow, so meow, so meow, so meow!
Sleep, meow, meow, meow, meow I believe they never meow.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow Good times never seem so meow
Yeah!
Sweet meow meow!
Oh yeah!
I saw you coming by today's comment of it!
Yay!
I'm so jealous about it.
But also, were you able to meet the developer I heard from
other Ace Combat, the Devil sometimes watch people play in
the demo.
Ah, AKSYF2Taku!
Um, I, there was only the brand of a brand director, um,
that I know that was there.
There was other people from the Japanese side, but I do not
know if, uh, you'll not see the meow coming.
I do not know if they were developers at all, um, uh, but
after, after everything, I saw the japanese stuff in the
lobby of the hotel they were leaving and i was like matara
i'm gonna work up the courage and i'm gonna go say oh to
them and so i did and i said i said i'm looking forward to
the game and i had a lot of fun and thank you for your hard
work and so i did we now bring
well played please sing hell fire I didn't have that on my
list but that does sound fun to sing hell meow meow meow
fire they grow up so fast I can't imagine Konosensei seeing
I don't want them to see me play there was one guy there
named Ace Combat Fan and I was like glued to the screen
studying his movements i was like because oh basically there
was there was the play the two the two parts of gameplay and
then at the end of the at the end of the event they had a
like score based tournament i almost signed up for it but
then i was like ah but what if i want to leave the event
sort of early i was like oh what if i want to leave the
early so um but uh so he was on the big screen that big
screen in the photo that i showed with like the the people
that participated in the contest sat at those like those
cockpit looking booths so um so yeah and uh i i was like
there it was really sweet though because there were people
that that were there that had never played for the ever
before and like it was really fine to watch like it was
people of all skill levels so so when does the minkitty
cover album drop uh matara and i met this really nice girl
she was very sweet and so i was like oh my gosh
it was really fun to just kind of talk and meet people
matara has a lot of friends she would be like oh i know this
person they're so and so blah blah And I was like, Hello.
Hi.
And then.
And then she would be like, Oh, this is, this is, do you
know Minto?
And they would be like, Oh, didn't you have like a podcast
together?
And I'm like, Mitara is an introvert's nightmare.
She actually is.
This is my first introvert ever.
Yesterday was my birthday.
Get a good happy birthday song for the greatest ghost made.
A rabblees.
Call me!
Happy birthday!
You know what?
It was some other people's birthdays too, so I was saying a
happy birthday.
They all got the Ace Combat CC, it was awesome.
Right!
Let's see.
They had some jackets that I really wanted to.
The staff and stuff.
I was like, dang.
I want a jacket, please.
I want a jacket.
Wait, this is a rock version.
Let's try it.
Happy birthday to you Happy birthday to you Happy birthday
to you Happy birthday to you How old are you now?
How old are you now?
Say it's your birthday, it's your birthday How old are you
now?
Happy birthday to you Happy birthday to you Happy birthday,
happy birthday Happy birthday to you To you To you Tell you
They're screaming Happy birthday Happy birthday I'll sing
Hellfire
There was one story That Matara talked about I cannot
remember it for the life of me But I just remember being
like actually a terrifying creature you are actually so
scary like how how do you how do you exist how i was talking
to a friend uh the other day that was just like oh like we
were talking about until dawn because the until dawn 2
announcement and just how like people in until dawn like are
there are people out there that act like these people in
these in these caves that are just so strange like as an
introvert i truly can't understand like i guess it's like
kind of i guess with uh with with uh with uh what was i
saying oh wait with with not returning pertaining to matara
But like with Until Dawn, sorry, I was reading stuff.
I was reading Super Chess.
With Until Dawn, like it's kind of like more frat culture,
you know?
It feels like.
I don't think Matara's just that.
But it's like an extrovert frat culture or something.
It's like so I've never, ever experienced like that.
Like the time she went to a random person and asked them,
the drive like yes exactly she will just go to she will go
to restaurants and things and she'll like see someone and be
like hey you want to like come hang out later what meeting
for the first how do you exist like
she'll just invite people that she doesn't know to her part
like not parties but like like to hang out and stuff like
with a group of friends too powerful she's like actually the
most extroverted person it's so terrifying did you know he's
combat fan actually used your hornet tour as a source where
you broke the no way really wait actually it's so funny that
the hornet tour was mentioned because um uh the there's the
two guys that used to be buzzfeed unsolved and Shane they're
now watcher and they released today they still do like ghost
hunting videos and stuff and they release today the Hornet
and and and there there is Gabe Jeff in the video and it's
so funny because because Shane of out of the duo Shane is
very like I don't believe in ghosts which is so funny he's
Yoshi because his attitude towards it is so funny but he but
Gabe was telling a story and Shane was like usually during
these like explanations I'm so bored but I'm so immersed in
your story you're a great storyteller and I was like oh my
gosh Gabe my Yoshi complimented you wow I was like oh my
gosh this is so funny I'm like one degree away from from
them now but that's so funny that ace combat fan used my
tour i didn't realize that actually it's funny because um i
got a comment uh from state my state of play oh nemi come
back hello hello everybody hello naplings hello welcome
thanks for the all right thank you so much i'm uh i'm i'm
happy to see you again nemi the auto feeder was over we were
We're starving.
Risen Glitchways, thank you for the gifted.
Torgo, thank you.
Thank you, don't thank you.
Xenopho, thank you.
We can't stand through.
Thank you.
Her worlds are colliding.
It was very strange.
Thank you.
I hope we
can hang out again soon sometime.
But I hope you had an amazing time off.
I hope it was so nice.
But yeah, someone commented on my state of play.
they were like hey actually did you know that um that the
hornet was used for for modeling the ship in ace combat
eight and i don't remember i don't think i commented but i
wanted to be like yeah that news was broke on my stream
crazy i can't believe i could assist in the ace combat world
like that i feel i feel you know two of the games quite
literally so I don't want to you know feel like I don't want
to say like I'm such a huge ginormous fan like I know
everything but so far everybody has been so nice and source
me I know right but I am still getting into the series I
don't want people to think I'm a fake fan What, what's the,
oh, the word, the, the kids, they say, they say, LARPER!
I'm not.
But I just think it's so funny that little, little old mate
was able to break that information.
Name every plane.
F-22, F-16, A-10.
When the strange real makes the real strange.
But yeah!
A-10, baby.
Vint is the world's most kawaii!
Don't know what to name you.
Let's see.
Um, what do I want to sing next?
I have, oh wait, I was gonna sing Hellfire, that's right.
Let's sing some Disney.
Kids don't say poser nowadays.
Right, what happened to that?
Oh, the language, the English language is evolving way too
fast.
I'm a ghost stuck in like 2010.
Wow.
Hellfire.
Wait, musical?
Wait, I think I messed up.
I think I chose the wrong one.
Hold on.
I have to, like, skip the beat.
beginning of the song though because I don't know this part
wait oh
yeah I think I have to skip Quasimodo or we can let him sing
himself go go have you guys ever actually done larping live
action role-playing I've only done it once I was I've never
done like a D&D or anything like that same but yeah i did
once it was kind of fine to like i was i was acting as like
a princess
did it for many years and kiss my cheek without a trace of
fright i feel bad for like the actual people that like lark
because their their term is being taken over by it by like
people that are turning it into a negative word but it's not
supposed to be supposed to be just fun
thank you quasi
did a fighting focus lark once I wear all archers.
That sounds awesome.
Also welcome to membership.
Welcome.
Beata Maria, you know I am a righteous ghost.
Of my virtue, I am justly proud.
Beata Maria, you know I'm so much purer than the common
vulgar, weak, licentious crowd.
Then tell me, Maria, why I see her dancing there, why her
smoldering eyes still scorch my soul.
I feel her, I see her, the sun caught in her raven hair is
blazing me out all of...
Wait, the draw!
Like fire, hell fire.
This fire in my skin, this burning desire is turning me to
sin.
It's not my fault, I'm not to blame.
It is the gypsy girl, the witch who sent this flame.
It's not my fault, it's within God's plan.
much stronger than a man.
Protect me, Miao Ria.
Don't let this siren cast her spell.
Don't let her fire steer my flesh and bone.
Destroy Esmeralda!
And let her taste the fires of hell, or else let her be mine
and mine alone.
Minister Frollo.
Ah, my name is Mint Phantom.
What?
in the cathedral.
She's gone.
Oh, but how?
Never mind.
Get out, you idiot.
I'll find her.
I'll find her if I have to burn down all of Paris.
Hellfire, dark fire.
Now, Gypsy, it's your turn.
Choose me, Lior, your buyer.
Be minor.
You will God have mercy on her.
God have mercy on me.
But she will be mine, nor she will burn.
Hellfire, Hellfire.
I wonder if I could sing that other song.
The other hunchback song.
Oh, there.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow.
One second.
Please?
I'll try it.
Wow, shady note tags.
Thank you so much for the 50.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I guess we don't really need the...
The subscriber thing anymore, huh?
Safe behind these windows and these parapets of stone Gazing
at the people down below me All my life I watch them as I
hide up here alone Hungry for the histories they show me All
my life I memorize their faces Knowing them as they will
never know All my life I wonder how it feels to pass a day
Not above them, but part of them And out there, living in
the sun Give me one day out there All I ask is one to hold
forever Out there, where they all live unaware What I give,
what I dare Just to live one day out there
Out there among the millers and the weavers and their wives
Through the roofs and gables I can see them Every day they
shout and scold and go about their lives Ain't less of the
gift it is to be them If I was in their skin a treasure
Every instant out there Strolling by the sand Taste of
mourning out there Like ordinary men Who freely bought the
bell there Just one day and then I swear I'll be content
With my share Won't resent, won't despair Hold and bend, I
won't care I'll have spent one day
there I wasn't sure if I was gonna hit those I was scared
thank you everybody thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you
I need to drink more water today hold on actually let me do
my little throat spray delicious minty fresh thank you for
the flowers thank you
i kind of want okay can we get into my dad era oh my gosh
david cereal thank you so much for the fit to get there
thank you i wanted to sing actually hold on no there's a
couple more things i want to sing before we into my dad era.
I don't know.
I feel like I want to test myself with doing more different
kinds of songs than what I usually do.
So, thank you for doing this karaoke while I'm working.
It's a stressful day today.
Psychic maniac!
Good luck!
You got this!
Did a King Henry VIII and his Reformation Parliament LARP in
college.
No physical combat, although we did get a surprise rated by
armed guards.
Wait, that's so far!
That's so fun.
I mean, though, I went to MCM London a couple of weeks ago.
I got to see David Hayter and Cam Clark.
And it made me think of you.
Thanks for being an inspiration to me and to do cool things.
Like, go to cards.
Ah, Coezy!
I hope you had so much fun.
Currently, there is a set.
But also, I don't know that one.
I'm so sorry.
sorry mcm i think i saw people posting about that one is i
guess is is all of is or not all of europe but is like a
majority of places uh over there are you guys all kind of
experiencing like this heat wave that germ i know germany
was pretty dang hot wasn't it like 30 degrees or something
oh i'm proud of you for hitting that last note Thank you,
Gabu!
Thank you.
It was torture.
Yeah, 33!
Oh my goodness.
El Nino all summer.
Not in Scandinavia.
Even worse here in Italy.
Oh no!
It was really hot in the UK last week, but it's passed now.
That's good.
Hopefully it cools down for you guys.
33.
yuck yuck it was 35 in london yuck but i guess like um uh
what was it it's but it does not it's not so humid right or
is it if it's hot but not humid that's always better i don't
know if you were watching rezero this season i wanted to
know your thoughts no spoilers i haven't started it yet But
I've heard very good things.
Only 33 laughs in Australian.
You have to understand, though, that the higher temperatures
are not as common, right?
Kind of human, not like sea.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a good watch and joy.
I heard some people saying it's like, it kind of brings back
like the mystery and everything of the first season.
Can we get a karaoke with puppet Minto, my Oshi?
Will, I hate to tell you, but I don't have...
The puppet...
The puppet is gone.
I don't have it anymore.
I'm sorry.
The puppets have been sold.
Sold off.
I'm sorry.
Probably...
I wish I could have done more with them before the Faname
auction, but...
Yeah.
I'm so sorry.
Let's take this song next.
I think it's been a long time since I've done this one.
Ooh.
Goblin hour.
Where we all pretend to be goblins for one whole hour.
Oh, wait.
What?
Wait, I can't remember what I...
I can't remember what key I put it at.
Plus three?
I think maybe.
Let me hear it.
Plus two?
Maybe plus two.
Okay, I restart.
Pretend.
It was just two lovers.
Sitting in the car, listening to blonde falling for each
other.
Pink and orange skies, feeling super childish, no Donald
Glover.
Miss call from my mother.
Like where you at tonight.
Got no alibi.
I was all alone with the love.
I'm alive She's got glitter for skin My radiant beam in the
night I don't need no light To see you shine It's your
golden hour Oh, you slow down
I'm in your goal
You were just two lovers, feet up on the dash, driving
nowhere fast, burning through the summer, radio on blast,
make the moment last, she got solar power, minutes feel like
hours, she knew she was the baddest, can you even imagine,
falling like I did for the love of my life, she's got glow
on her face, a glorious look in her eyes.
My angel of light I was all alone with the love of my life
She's got glitter for skin A radiant beam in the night I
don't need no light to see you shine
It's your golden,
you slow down time.
You guys say I'm disgusting.
You guys say I bring up pee too much.
But anytime I sing this song, inevitably there's someone
yelling golden shower in the comments.
I can't take it anymore.
No more golden shower.
I'm blocking it from my chat.
What about golden meower?
Stop urination.
No, don't do that.
You guys have to pee.
or else it's dangerous you have to pee don't hold it in
obligatory golden sofa golden super chat
stay hydrated I don't even know the golden shower version
because I'm not a freakazoid like I don't even know it.
I held it in for you.
That's the opposite.
You have to pee.
It's good for your body.
The stone told me otherwise.
I actually don't know it.
It's your golden shower.
Pissy booze rise up.
Don't do that.
You tell me pee is good for me.
Yeah.
Well, pee-ing is good for you.
Pee-ing is good for you.
We shouldn't...
Don't fetishize it.
It's adorable bodily function.
Everybody has to do it.
Flame Juna for singing at the concert.
Phantom thief, right?
Really just set the tone for the rest of the night, maybe.
We're weird, but you love us, right?
Command received, piss his pants.
I mean, you are free to piss your pants.
I will not tell you not to piss your pants, but I will...
You have those...
That's your consequence to face.
Thinking of Minto and I.
When what?
Put some newspaper down first.
Don't, don't, don't, don't degrade yourself to animals.
No.
We're bashful kidneys in China.
Hibus will flood the lands with yellow.
Chew, it's.
Oh, yeah.
Man, you guys are all such sickos and freaks.
But you are my sickos and freaks.
I bear this responsibility.
Mrs. Spencer, are you in a talk to?
I'm listening to Mint Shouting Golden Shower while working.
Good thing I got headphones on.
I'm so sorry.
Can you do the cover you did with Nimi?
I don't think I could do that one actually by myself.
I think that one actually might be too tough.
No.
But hopefully one day we can sing it together.
That'll be fun.
Sing it together again or something, you know.
Thank you for giving us a space to just be kind of freaky.
Yeah.
Let's see.
This is for all the iBus who didn't make it in time to the
letterbox!
I think iBus are trained to use the...
Have you ever seen like a cat that's trained to use the
toilet?
I think everybody is trained to use a toilet.
We live and freak by your orders.
A favorite of mine's things and everything you do, yeah,
they were all yellow.
Really glad you guys like yellow so much, but if your pee is
that yellow, then it's actually dangerous.
Continuing the yellow.
It should be much more clear than this.
I'm concerned for you guys.
Drink more water.
Yeah, drink more water.
Are there other songs about P in the set list?
There were no songs about P in the set list at all.
No songs that I have sung have been about P. I'm leaving.
Couldn't find a clear sub.
Make sure to hydrate.
Yeah, everybody hydrate.
Here.
I'll get to you guys.
Oh, I know what.
I could stop you.
I could stop you here and now.
I could do it.
Wait.
I'll...
Wait, hold on.
I have to make sure this is good to use to sing.
Okay, Melby.
I use code Boomer to buy gamer subs because it helps me
relieve my...
Stop that.
It helps you relieve your stress.
Yeah.
Reminder, if yours is this yellow seek help right.
Meow.
okay i'm gonna sing a song and we're leaving this topic
behind this song after this song no more mention after this
song no more mention okay got it out of your system
says you it's my stream
take over you guys are you guys are observing me and my
power
This is a mutiny, mutiny.
I'm getting hijacked.
You can't take over.
You are not.
Okay, wait.
You want to be Minto?
You guys want to be Minto?
Or sing for me?
Sing for me.
My angels of music.
Out of my system.
On to the floor.
Meow.
to me.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
Everybody turns to meows.
Windstream.
Oh, my God.
How do you guys...
You guys don't run out of these at all.
It's like you waited for this day.
You're like, oh, my gosh, finally, Mint is talking about pee
again.
All my pee jokes.
I can finally say them every single one of them.
It's been...
458 days!
I've waited for this!
Okay, there.
We have a Google Doc full of them.
Google Dockey.
So I'm not ascending the Godhood.
I'm just dehydrated.
Yeah.
That's what they all tell you.
But it's actually just a lie.
It's a myth.
Okay, I'm sorry.
singing i'm singing it's karaoke stream after this i feel
like i'm commanding a kindergarten class you guys can all
say six seven right now and and oh what's another brain rot
um you can all say it get it say it out of your system real
fast and then after that no more
It's a coup.
We call it the yellow revolution.
We're all just turning 12.
We are in rare form tonight, boss.
What does that mean?
Roku nana.
Can you sing yellow by gold play?
Wait.
How does that song go?
Wait, do I actually know this one?
I don't think I know the whole thing, but we could drop.
Let's just do it anyway.
You're so sick.
Look how they shine for you And everything you do Yeah, they
were all yellow I came along I wrote a song for you And all
the things you do And it was called the yellow.
What a thing to have.
Wait, I can't remember.
I'm gonna sing with him because I don't remember the song.
It was all yellow.
Your skin, oh yeah, your skin and bones.
Turn into something beautiful.
Cause you know.
You know I love you so Oh I love you so
I swam across I jumped across for you Oh what a thing to do
Cause you were all yellow I drew a line, I drew a line for
you Oh what a thing to do And it was all yellow
Your skin, oh yeah, your skin levels Turned into something
beautiful Cause you know you knew I'd bleed myself dry Oh
you knew I'd bleed myself dry Look
how they shine for you They shine for you Look how they
shine for you shine for you look how they shine for you
look at the stars look how they shine for you and all the
things that you do man okay i'm going to dad rock now I
think people will like this one.
I like this song.
Okay, yeah, it's here.
On a dark desert highway.
Cool wind in my hair.
Warm smell of colitas rising up through the air.
Up ahead in the distance.
I saw a shimmering light.
and my sight grew dim.
I had to stop for the night.
There she stood in the doorway.
I heard the mission bell.
And I was thinking to myself, this could be heaven or this
could be hell.
Then she lit up a candle and she showed me the way.
There were voices in the corridor.
I thought I heard them say Welcome to the Hotel California
Such a lovely place Such a lovely face Plenty of room at the
Hotel California Any time of year You can find it here Her
mind is Tiffany twisted She's got the Mercedes-Benz She's
got a lot of pretty, pretty boys That she calls friends How
they dance in the courtyard Sweet summer sweat Some dance to
remember Some dance to forget So I called up the captain
Please bring me my wine He said we haven't had that spirit
here since 1969 And still those voices are calling from far
away They wake you up in the middle of the night Just to
hear them say Welcome to the Hotel California Such a lovely
place Such a lonely face They're living it up at the hotel,
California What a nice surprise Bring your alibis Oh, sorry,
I was about to yawn But you're like The pink champagne on
ice She said, we are all just prisoners here Of our own
divine And in the master's chambers They gathered for their
feast They stab it with their steely knives But they just
can't kill the beast Last thing I remember I was running for
the door I had to find a passage back to the place I was
before Relax said the night man We are programmed to receive
You can check out anytime you like But you can never leave
Iconic What's this song about?
It's about this game called Mystery of the Druids That's
right, you can't Wow, what?
They cut out the entire guitar solo Sorry, I thought the
guitar or what happened what was it gonna say I don't
remember wait what was I gonna say
oh well anyway
such a lovely place such a lovely face bam bam
you can you can you, you can never leave Minto channel.
Okay?
Ninja Prince has a song called P Control on the album, The
Gold Experience.
I did not know that.
Why would you bring that up?
Oh, I can't stop yawning.
Let's, I'm gonna sing another song so I don't.
Mystery of the Druids is my favorite obscure game set of
streams.
I'm so happy.
into reference.
I'm gonna sing another song so that I can not sleep.
I don't wanna fall asleep.
And I also I don't wanna close my eyes.
Oh my gosh, wait, that was the greatest segue ever.
I could stay awake just to hear you breathing.
Watch you smile while you're sleeping.
and dreaming I could spend my life in this sweet surrender I
could stay lost in this moment forever every moment spend
with you is a moment I treasure I don't I don't want to fall
asleep Cause I'd miss you, baby And I don't want to miss a
thing Cause even when I dream of you The sweetest dream I'll
never do I'd still miss you, baby And I don't want to miss a
thing Lying close to you Feeling your heart beating And I'm
wondering what you're dreaming Wondering if it's me you're
seeing Then I kiss your eyes And thank God we're together
And I just want to stay with you In this moment forever
Forever and ever I don't want to close my eyes I don't wanna
fall asleep Cause I miss you, meow And I don't wanna meow a
thing Cause even when I meow of you The sweetest meow I'll
never do I'd still meow your babe And I don't wanna meow a
thing I don't wanna miss one smile I don't wanna miss one
kiss Well, I just wanna be with you right here, with you
just like this.
I just wanna hold you close.
I feel your heart so close to mine.
And just stay here in this moment for the rest of time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Don't wanna close my eyes Don't wanna fall asleep Cause I
miss you, baby And I don't wanna miss a thing Cause even
when I dream of you The sweetest dream we'll never do Cause
I still miss you, baby And I don't wanna miss a thing I
don't wanna close my eyes
I think
I should have tried that one beforehand and change the key,
but that's okay.
I confirm my new neighbors are cool because they haven't
knocked on my door during that.
Yippee!
Yeah.
Don't want to close my eyes.
What movie was that from again?
Um, the space movie.
Uh, what was it called?
Um, Armageddon, yes!
Armageddon.
Wow, classic.
I have a question.
If you guys have seen Project Hail Mary, you might know that
there's like a bit of a rivalry between Interstellar and
Project Hail Mary.
I've seen both.
And I prefer Project Hail Mary.
But which do you guys like?
You can say both.
You saw it last night?
Oh my gosh, so good.
I love it.
I prefer Project Hail Mary.
I like both.
Project Hail Mary better.
I wouldn't say it's a rivalry.
I don't know.
It's a friend.
You could have friendly rivalries.
It's not like anything serious.
Project Tailmery is cuter.
That's true.
Interstellar.
I'm not familiar with them.
I recommend Project Tailmery so much.
I think I've said it like so many times on stream before.
But it's seriously like my movie of the year.
I love it so much.
Interstellar the film Project Tailmery the book.
Oh, that's valid too.
That's so valid.
Hmm.
interstellar is great but the ending is dumb i think
interstellar really hit people at the time you know in the
kokoro and so it's really hard to like kind of let go of it
a little bit i guess like it was the like kokoro feeling um
space movie i feel like for a long time i still hear people
use like the soundtrack of it it has a really great
soundtrack thing and it's kind of got i wouldn't say it's a
twist but it's got like a bittersweet aspect of it and that
always gets people too
you didn't like it interstellar that's that much i i when i
watched it for the first time i watched it because so many
people like were saying like oh my gosh it's so great and i
watched it and And I just, I also felt, I didn't dislike it,
but I felt kind of lukewarm on it.
You know what I mean?
I was kind of just like, oh, hmm.
And this is coming from someone that loves tragic and
bittersweet endings.
So for me to kind of be like, ah, hmm.
Yeah, I felt okay about it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I feel like Interstellar is like the experience.
It's very C and IMAX film to me.
Oh, really?
Maybe that's where I messed up.
Maybe that's where I... I got...
I didn't get the full experience.
I still love Interstellar.
That's good, though.
It's good to love Interstellar.
Love what you love, you know?
Not everybody's gonna...
Everybody loves different things, and that's why it's so fun
that we have different things that exist.
Yeah.
Han Zimmer OSTs are always good yeah
big stretch okay let's see I'm in like a movie mood now did
anybody go see amazing digital circus did anybody go see
amazing digital circus I think that started today no
no no no don't spoil I didn't watch it you're going on
Sunday how fun yeah the amazing digital circus
couple cancelled his ticket to be here don't say that oh I
literally He just came back from seeing that movie tonight.
Did you like it?
I hope your audience was okay.
Like, I hope the people in the theater.
That's the scariest part to me.
It's the people in the theater.
It's true.
Why would you do that?
There's a vibe, you goof.
What are you doing?
Uh...
I'm waiting for it to start right now.
Have fun!
It's a very bittersweet ending.
I feel emotionally exhausted after seeing you.
Oh no!
Well then, let's sing some more to get the feeling.
Here, let's sing a fun...
Well, it's not fun, but...
It's a little more...
It's a little more peppy song.
A little more peppy song.
Let's try this one.
I heard you on the wireless back in 52 Flying away contently
tuning on you If I was young, it didn't stop you coming
through Oh, you can't hear it Oh my gosh, sorry Wait, can
you hear it?
Wait, oh, you could Oh, I'm so sorry, sorry I got mixed up
with my interface Sorry, sorry.
Sorry, sorry.
I heard you on the wireless back in 52.
Lying away, contently tuning in on you.
If I was young, it didn't stop you coming through.
Oh, oh, oh.
They took the credit for your second symphony, Written by a
machine on new technology And now I understand the problems
you could see Oh, I met your children Oh, what did you tell
them?
Video killed the radio star Video killed the radio star
Pictures came and broke your heart Oh, oh, oh, oh And now we
meet in an abandoned studio We hear the playback and it
seems so long ago And you remember the jingles used to go
Oh, oh, you were the first one You were the last one Video
killed the radio star Video killed the radio star In my mind
and in my car We can't rewind, we've gone too far Oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh Video killed a radio star Video killed a radio star
In my mind and in my car We can't rewind, we've gone too far
Pictures came and broke your heart Put the blame on VCR
Radio Star You are Radio Star Video killed the radio star
Video killed the radio star Video killed the radio star
Video killed the radio star Video killed the radio Video
killed the radio star Yeah!
The TV bringer the news.
I heard this live when Asia played it in like 2007.
Whoa!
That's so crazy.
That's fun.
Let's see.
Hmm.
killed the radio star was my very first very last video
played on mtv was it actually wait but mtv is still like
going no don't they play um trash tv digital circus movie is
better sweet you'd like it really i'll go see it then well
i'll see it when they release it in two weeks NTV is gone
They shut down the music channels Oh my gosh Oh oh like it's
not music TV
But also Watching TV Though I kind of think it's like I kind
of missed the days where I didn't have to choose what I
watched.
Does that make sense?
Like I didn't have to shift through and sift through like
millions and millions of videos and movies and TV shows.
Kind of missed the day where it was just like, oh this is
on, that's so exciting.
Or like when your favorite show is on that night, like a new
episode and you're like, oh my gosh, I can't wait till I get
to watch my favorite show tonight.
It was pretty fun.
Pretty fun, I think.
If you haven't seen the 2007 movie, Sunshine is incredible.
The soundtrack to Loom is so good.
Great space film.
Oh, I was looking into it.
Thank you, Robo.
Wait, all week for Yenu Yasha.
Yeah!
I mean, I guess if you were, like, watching something and
then you're like, oh, I...
I...
What's the word?
Uh...
i i have to wait until the next episode tonight after i get
off work or something but i don't know it just has different
feeling right
yeah they were just saying that about the video killed the
radio store yeah yeah yeah it sucks because it's harder to
connect with people based on what shows they watch
everyone's in that has their own worlds that's true too like
the watch Walking Dead would premiere and everybody in the
office will be talking about it the next day, right?
Be like, oh, did you see that episode of The Walking Dead?
Because these days we'll never know the commercial Break
Snack Rush.
Hmm.
Like, it's great that we have so much media, but we also
have so much media.
It's fun that we have lots of different stuff that we can
watch, but we have so much stuff we can watch.
I don't know.
Game of Thrones.
I didn't watch Game of Thrones though.
I'm never seeing maybe one of the one of the last ghosts on
Earth that hasn't seen Game of Thrones.
I haven't even seen like a single episode.
You neither?
We are of the same innocence.
We are Game of Thrones innocence.
I'm kind of glad though because I feel like I would have
really gotten sucked into it and then with how things
happened i had a friend she was so she was like the red
wedding the red wedding you must watch me though and i was
like okay i'll get around to it and uh it's so sad how it
how the ending ruined its reputation that was a kid we had
an antenna so he only got the six to ten channels that were
broadcast over the year on the plus side no subscriptions
nice i remember having a big antenna in my backyard and
climbing it.
I would climb that thing like a tree and like slide down it
and stuff.
It was a huge antenna.
I also haven't seen only read books, but I hear Game of
Thrones really struck the landing.
Face first at the ground.
Yeah, like a dish.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What do you mean by slide down?
Like a, like, like, was concave right and so i'd use it like
a slide i'd just be like like that you know right you guys
well maybe not everybody had as big of a dish as i did
that huge dish and still no disney channel that huge antenna
no disney channel hmm how big was it like Three Minto's.
It was really big.
It was like, like, it was very, very large.
Like, it was really huge.
And I'd climb it.
Girl, I was getting alien.
Yeah, I watched the Futurama.
Uh, uh,
three whole mintos
yeah huge I don't know why it was like kind of rusty too
maybe it didn't work I don't know I have no idea why that
thing was in my backyard now that I think about it I wonder
if it's still there I wonder if I like street viewed that
place if I could see it stop making me oh I don't see
Sorry.
I'm so sleepy today.
Let's sing some more so I don't fall asleep.
Wait.
I wonder if they have the techno-y version of this song.
Oh, let's see.
Oh, dance version.
I think that's it.
Hold on.
Let me double check it.
La la la.
I think so.
Yeah.
Dance mix.
dance mix dance mix yeah yeah but it's oldie oldie song
oldie song
I used to watch it I knew Yasha and beat to the song
every now and then I get a little bit lonely and you're
never coming round every now and then I get a little bit I'm
tired of listening to the sound of my tears.
Every now and then I get a little bit nervous that the best
of all the years have gone by.
Every now and then I get a little bit terrified and then I
see the look in your eyes.
Bright eyes.
Every now and then I fall apart.
And I need you more than ever And if you'll only hold me
tight We'll be holding on forever And we'll only be making
it right Cause we'll never be wrong To get it up on a time I
was falling in love Now I'm only falling apart There's
nothing I can do A total eclipse of the heart
Every now and then I know you'll never be the boy you always
wanted to be Well, every now and then I know you'll always
be the only boy who wanted me the way that I am Every now
and then I know there's no one in the universe as magical
and wondrous as you Every now and then I know there's
nothing any better There's nothing that I just couldn't do
Every now and then I fall apart Every now and then I fall
apart And I need you now tonight And I need you more than
ever And if you'll only hold me tight We'll be holding on
forever
Cause we'll never be wrong Together we can take it to the
end of the line And love is like a shadow on me all of the
time I don't know what to do, I'm always in the dark We're
living in a powder keg and giving all sparks I really need
you tonight
Ever's gonna start to Once upon a time I was falling in love
Now I'm only falling apart There's nothing I can do The
total eclipse of the heart Once upon a time I was falling in
love Now I'm only falling apart There's nothing I can do A
total eclipse of the heart
Yay!
That was the Nikki French version
I watched...
I don't think I've heard that song in so long version but I
watched that Inuyasha music video so many times that
Inuyasha AMV at least a hundred thousand times and I I
that's how I can't I love it can we see it I don't even know
if I could find it anymore let me wait I'll look it up I'll
look it up let's see total it wait You know, Yasha.
AMV.
Total eclipse of the heart.
Oh!
Is this it?
It is.
Oh wait,
I'm gonna get copyright struck for real.
Look
it up!
You guys can find it!
I literally told you what to look up.
It's the very first thing no way guys it's from 2008 looks
so grainy
it's like i think it's actually oh no it's 480p it's from
2008 that's insane
my channel dates back to that year holy cow that's crazy i
don't even know if i had a youtube channel back then i think
i just went on youtube there was nothing that i was looking
up that was sussy or anything so i didn't well also i was a
kid just a little baby ghost so um but yeah
hope to see more east combat 8 on summer games i didn't know
if they would talk about it at the state of play or summer
games fest when i realized there was a state of play i was
like oh i think i need to watch both I was like, oh, wait.
I need to do both.
Let's see.
We'll do this song because I like this one.
I've done this one before.
I've done this song before.
Wait, but I have to...
Plus two.
A key.
Plus two key.
There is freedom within.
Try to catch the delusion of paper call A
loss, but you'll never see the end of the road When you're
traveling with me Hey now, hey now Don't dream it's over Hey
now, hey now When the world comes in They come, they come To
build a wall between us We know they won't win
Now I'm towing my car There's a hole in the roof My
possessions are causing me suspicion But there's no In the
paper today Tales of war and of waste But you turn right
over to the TV page Hey now, hey now, don't dream it's over
Hey now, hey now, when the wall comes in They come, they
come To build a wall between us We know they won't win And
I'm counting the steps to the door of your heart
ahead, barely clearing the roof, yet to know the feeling of
liberation and release.
Hey now, hey now, don't dream it's over, hey now, hey now,
when the war comes in, they come, they come to build a wall
between us, we know they can't win.
But don't
let them win
Don't dream it's over Hey now, hey now Meow, hey meow, hey
meow Meow, meow, meow, meow I wonder if this is on here
Extra bonus, yeah, extra bonus i'm gonna sing this song now
it's been a minute since i've sung this song too
oh oh wait what did i just oh
blind in the deepest night reaching out grasping for
fleeting memory all these thoughts keep piercing this broken
mind i fall but i'm still standing motionless.
Far in the distance, there's light, a light that burns these
scars of old.
All this pain reminds me of what I am.
become all I need to be
whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
was that kill Would you speak lamb to me With your breath so
still It makes me believe In the Father's sins Let me suffer
now and never die I'm alive
Feeds their blackened hearts And the thirst must be quenched
To fuel hypocrisy Cleansing flames is the only way to repent
Renounce what made you worse That's kill Would you speak
them to me Breath so still, it makes me believe The sins
never die Can't watch this blood off our hands Let the world
fear us all It's just me, it's to an end Our salvation lies
Beyond the truth, let me suffer now
In my heart I just know that there's no way to light up the
dark In his love
Whoa, whoa
words that kill would you speak them to me so cool that was
sin to the father sin to the father yeah wait I need some
more water though I'll be right back actually would say,
amaze, amaze, amaze.
I was starting to lose it because I ran out of water.
Bad timing, bad timing.
Um, .
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Give me one second.
Wait, what was I doing?
Oh, music.
Oh, boy, J.M.
Boy J.M.
This, the, the, the, this one.
Oh, wait a minute.
Oh, I don't need my...
I don't need this anymore.
La la la la la.
Um, num, num, num.
Wait, don't give me us that I look.
What was I doing?
Sorry, Astro projected to get water.
I don't know what I look like once I'm out.
I don't... Was I small?
Smug?
My default look?
Smug.
Zako, zako, zako.
Your AFK faces have been extremely smug as of late.
What can I say?
I can't say anything.
Like actually what can I say?
What can I say?
Konogaki!
No.
I have some other bad songs, but I don't know.
Some of these are the ones that I'm less confident about.
I could still try them.
I could still try.
Go for it.
Yeah.
Winner takes it all.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
They're good songs though.
I like them a lot.
Sing whatever you're in the mood for.
Yeah.
Ah.
I kind of want to sing a Disney song.
Or maybe.
Wicked.
I've been watching.
I watched a Wicked movie again recently.
Wicked.
The Wicked songs are so, like, intense, though.
I need to wait so I can have some water.
Wait.
Wicked weaned.
Oh my gosh.
I actually do have Miku songs on Karofun.
That's crazy.
I'll try it.
I've never...
I don't know if I've ever sung this song before.
It's so crazy.
Maybe I have...
Oh, oh, my water.
It's like the Miku song.
The world is mine.
World is Miku.
I'll try it
Thank you.
One, Two, It's always a different Ka-Migata I'm done with
The other three, That's a cool damned It's never worth it
More than The three, Say The three Are the three And the
first Three answers I know My right hand Can't do it None of
you No, no, no.
No, no, no to eat right now, right it's
not true, I won't forgive you that, um, I'm not listening to
you I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry I'm sorry, I'm sorry
I got it The Earth
The world The
world The world The shortcake Codow The tomato I'm gonna
watch My Waga mama No Don't let me I'll be a part You will
I'll be
the one You The world The most You
The most You
It's so different listening to a song and then singing it.
That
was wonderful, really?
It was my first time ever singing it.
I hope you guys liked it.
Haunt Sunet Mintku.
Yo!
Let's see.
Let me go back to Wicked.
Hmm.
Maybe not Wicked.
I feel like...
world is me time let's see wait
I feel like the only wicked song I want to do is like wait
um
is like so long so I don't feel like singing it so it's like
I think like a seven minute song or something it's kind of
crazy long yeah it's like six minutes Ah, eh.
Okay.
Fleetwood Mac.
Yeah, I do, actually.
I wrote some down.
I mean, did that out here soon, but thanks so much for the
stream.
You're so talented.
Today's song list really took me through memories.
It's on great times and great people.
Have fun.
Thank you, Universal.
Bye.
Hopefully, I'll see you later.
Have fun.
Fleetwood Mac.
I'm trying to learn.
Uh, what's it called?
Wait, um, wait, uh...
Uh...
I'm trying to learn more Fleetwood Mac songs.
Like, I want to learn Silver Springs.
Time cast a spell on you.
You are with me.
It's going to be a VOD watcher, but congrats on bypassing
RST's restraining.
order.
What are you talking about?
Or she loves me.
No.
The chain is one of my favorites.
Let me listen to it real quick.
Let me see if I... Because sometimes I hear songs and I
don't realize what they are, you know.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I do know this one.
But I don't know if I'm confident to sing it today.
Listening to a and singing it is so different I feel let's
see we'll do this one this is the one I wrote down
it's only right that you should play the way you feel it but
listen carefully to the sound your loneliness like a
Heartbeat drives you mad In the stillness of remembering
What you had And what you lost And what you had And what you
lost Oh, thunder only happens when it's raining Players only
love you when you're playing Say, women, they will come and
they will go When the rain washes you clean, you'll know
You'll know
The crystal visions I keep my visions to myself It's only me
who wants to wrap around your dreams And have you any dreams
you'd like to sell Dreams of loneliness like a heartbeat
drives you mad in the stillness of remembering what you had
and what you lost and what you had what you lost Thunder
only happens when it's raining
Players only love you when they're playing Women, they will
come and they will go
Rainwashes you, clean you'll know Oh, thunder only happens
when it's raining Players only love you I love you when
you're playing Say women, they will come and they will go
Rain washes you clean you'll know You'll know You will know
Double feature
I saw my reflection in the snow covered hills, till the
landslide brought me down.
Oh, mirror in the sky, what is love?
Can the child within my heart rise above?
Can I sail through the changing ocean tides?
Can I handle the seasons?
my life.
I'm
afraid of changing because I've built my life around you.
But time makes it bolder, even children get older and I'm
getting older too.
I'm afraid of changing Cause I've built my life around you
But time makes it bolder Even children get older And I'm
getting older too Oh,
take my love, take it down Oh, climb
up And if you see my reflection Snow-covered hills, or the
landslide, bring it down.
And if you see it by reflection in the snow-covered hills,
or the landslide, bring it down.
Or the landslide, bring it down.
Double feature!
Yay!
Dreams and landslide.
Fleetwood Max.
Hits.
Yippee!
Thank you!
Thank you guys.
Let's see.
I can take that off the list.
Dreams.
I did both.
I wasn't going to do both, but I ended up doing both.
I probably should end it soon.
I don't know, how many, how many songs have I done today?
I don't even know.
Thank you, Vido.
Of course.
Simple and clean.
I feel like I've done that one a lot recently.
So probably not today.
17 songs.
Let's get to 19 because that's how old I am.
Or we could, no, we'll do 20.
We'll do 20.
We could do three more.
Three more, three more.
Forever 19.
Meow, meow.
I sing that one all the time, too, though.
But I love Dancing Queen.
One song.
For some reason, hot dog thing,
four, four, four, four, four, four, thank you, thank you,
thank you.
Um, what was I going to say?
Um, Abba's a bop, all right.
Oh, there's one song.
This is from Greece.
Hopelessly devoted.
For some reason, I can never, I can never remember how the
verses go, but I just know the chorus.
I kind of want to sing it, but like, I cannot know, I, you
know, but now there's no way to hide since you pushed my
love aside.
I'm out of my hand.
Hopelessly devoted to you.
My dad would always play Fleetwood Mac in the car, so
getting to hear you sing those songs is really nice.
Oh, thank you, Zabar.
It's the same, right?
I feel like probably a lot of these songs.
Like my dad was, these are definitely my dad's songs, you
know, so singing them, I get to think of the times that we
had.
Dad road trip songs.
Yeah.
When I think of them, I think of the time that we went on a
road trip and I really had to pee.
So he got on the, like the part of the road that you're not,
if we were stuck in a traffic jam and I really had to pee.
And so he drove on road where you're not supposed to and he
got pulled over by the cops and they're like you're not
supposed to drive here and he said my daughter has to pee oh
and so the cop let him go
yeah good times um hold on let me listen to the song real
quick and see if i can remember A lot of these are my dad
songs too, very nostalgic.
Thank you, Minto, of course.
Dad music rocks.
Wait, hold on.
There we go.
I think I remember how this song goes.
Uh, uh, uh, uh.
I think I could sing it.
I sing.
A horse.
A haunts with no name.
A haunt with no name.
I sing.
On the first part of the journey I was looking at all the
life There were plants and birds and rocks and things There
was sand and hills and rain The first thing I met was a
buzzing fly And the sky with no clouds The heat was hot and
the ground was dry But the air was full of sound I've been
through the desert on a horse with no name It felt good to
be out of a race In the desert you can remember your name
Because there ain't no one for to give me no pain.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la,
la, la.
After two days in the desert sun, my skin began to turn red.
After three days in the desert fun, I was looking at a river
bed.
And the story I told of a river that flowed made me sad to
think It was dim.
You see, I've been through the desert on a horse with no
name.
It felt good to be out of the rain.
In the desert, you can remember your name, because there
ain't no one for it to give you no pay.
La la, la, la, la, la, la,
la.
Giddy up, giddy up.
Clippy clock, clippy clock.
Nine days, I let the horse run free.
Because the desert had turned to sea There were plants and
birds and rocks and things There was sand and hills and
rings The ocean is desert with the life underground And the
perfect skies above Under the cities lies a heart made of
ground But the humans will give no love You see, I've been
through a desert on a horse with no dirt It felt good to be
out of the rain In the desert, you can remember your name
Cause there ain't no one for to give me no pain La la la la
la la
That became so scary La la Meantos world Oh
my gosh, I'm Minto Yes, I am La la la la la
Let's see, let's see, let's see, let's see Hmm
Why is it so good?
I don't know!
I have no idea!
I want to see it.
What Pokemon charge we have on here?
Then we have Brother My brother We only want to be with you
Hooting and the Blowfish Is this a Pokemon song?
I'm listening to it Why do I feel like I remember this one?
Crazy No, I don't think so I think I'm thinking of something
else It's not What the heck?
I was like Why would Hooting and the Blowfish Maybe I've
just heard the song before That's so funny Wait They have
the German version of the Pokerup.
Wait, I can sing the Pokerup.
Would it be the best?
There ever was to beat all the rest.
Yeah, that's my cause.
Electro-diglit, nidaran, nanky, Venusaur, without a hero,
pity-seeking, Jolteon, dragon, knight, gas-leave, he'll need
time before you.
All your rats, water-free.
Catch them, catch them, gotta catch them all.
Pokerman!
I'll search across the land, look far and wide.
Release from my hand the power that's inside.
Venomoth, Polywag, Nidorino, Gold Duck, Evisore, Grimer,
Victory Bell, Moth Trace, Needle King, Barfetch, Abra,
Jigglypuff, Kingler, Rhyhorn, Quaver, Wigglytuff Catch him,
catch him, gotta catch him all.
Gotta catch him all.
Pokemon!
Zubat, Primate, Meowth, Onyx, Geodude, Rapidash, Magneton,
Snorlax, Gengar, Tangela, Goldine, Spiro, Weir, Zeng, Seal,
Garado, Slowbro.
Gotta catch him all, gotta catch him all!
Gotta catch him all!
Gotta get some more Pokemon!
You're my favorite part!
Oh no, Miss Komuto!
Right, she's a Kairos horsey!
You're out of gear, I'm out of my cover, I'm out of a
weaving belt!
Little Closer, Caterpie, Shadowtrue, Bulbasaur, Shadow
Mender, Golem, Pikachu!
At least 150 or more to see!
To be a Pokemon!
Raptor is my...
Raptor?
Did I say Raptor?
Yeah!
Army!
Whoa!
We're at the halfway point.
Doing great so far!
We're still...
I'm doing all the hard work.
Break
window, Cleveri, Dordreo, Cedro, Villapun, Cravy, Machop,
Shelter, Corrigan, Timu-chan,
Garryo!
Articuno, Jinx!
Need I bring a Bidro, Hunter, Squirrel, Chanty!
Sorry, I just said Pokéro, that was...
At least 150 or more to see.
To be a Pokemon Monster is my destiny!
My champion, Sir Colfeng, Dugtrio, Gobat, Star, You,
Magicals, Eggens, Omastar, Scyther, Tentacle, Dragonair,
Magmar.
Whoa, catch your breath, man.
Check out those lips.
It's downhill from here.
Just 24 more to go.
Now it gets tricky, so listen real good.
Soundslash, Hitmanly, Scyther, Arcanine, TV, Executor,
Neotar, Zeptoes, Dratini, Growlith, Mr. Mime, Cubone,
Graveler, Voltorb, ooh!
Charmeleon!
Why, Tentacle!
New to Tentacle, Herald!
That's my favorite part of the song.
Sometimes I like have like a vocal stem that's just
Tarmillian
Tarmillian You two tentacle aerodactyl I'm a nice So poke
Chat, thank you
I know what you mean Oh, it's so good.
That's all, folks.
Gotta get your ball.
Charmeleon.
What do you mean?
Post Malone did a Pokemon song.
What is this from?
Pokemon what?
Pokemon 25.
Wait.
I don't know this song at all.
Did you guys?
The vocal stem is real.
It's so fun, though.
I don't know.
Wow!
Well, I have one more song left, right?
My throat is starting to get a little bit.
Like, this is the end.
It's a cover of the end of Bluefish song.
Wait, is it actually?
Wait, what the heck?
I know what I want to do.
I know for my final song.
my final song.
Thank you everybody for karaoke today.
Sorry I didn't, I guess dad, dad song was partially the
theme.
But today, for now, I bid you adieu after this final song.
And please stream, uh, burn on.
Hot blooded heroin.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh, okay, I think I could do this.
Okay.
I'm also hungry.
And now the end is near.
And so I face the final curtain.
My friends, I'll say it clear.
of which I'm certain I've lived a life that's full I've
traveled each and every highway
Much more than this I did it my
Regrets I've had a few But then again, too few to mention I
did what I had to do And saw it through without exemption I
planned each charted course Each careful step along the
boundary
Much more than this, I did it my way.
Yes, there were times, I'm sure you knew, when I bit off
more than I could chew, but through it all, when there was
doubt, Paint it up and spin it out I've based it all And I
stood tall And didn't mind
I've had my fill My share of a losing And now As tears
subside I find it all so amusing To think I did all that And
may I say Not in a shy way Oh no, oh no not me I did it my
For what is a man?
What has he got?
If not himself, then he has not to say the things he truly
feels, and not the words of one who kneels.
I took the gloves And did it my way
Yes, it was my
Sippy, sippy, sippy, sippy Have a good day, have a good
night Have a good time zone And thanks for joining me Thanks
for 4, 4, 4, 4, 4, 4, 4, 4 And yeah!
Thanks everybody!
I'm gonna go...
Thanks for the karaoke beat on my way, maybe a bit old.
Yeah, it's like a Grandad song.
But when it first came across your streams, it was one of
the first really resonated with me.
Oh, thank you for the nostalgia.
Glad to be...
I'm proud to...
You've done things your way.
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the pink.
Thank you for the flowers, everybody.
Thank you.
Thanks everyone!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Oh.
Hmm.
this was fun that was fun um Matara is Yappan uh she has a
photo of me Minky plush in her cleavage so I will raid into
her on YouTube beautiful singing Minto thank you thank you
so much for the pink digital canary thanks everybody thank
you bye bye bye
Hunt you later!
Bye bye!